[Music]
to my other i hope this reaches you well
i'm quite certain it won't of course i'm
really writing this to you
for me i'm sorry it's been so long
it's typically much easier to pretend
that i don't want to pretend you're
still here as time has passed
i've gotten better at it at convincing
myself i'm okay
and missing you without the feeling they
say grieving gets easier
it doesn't really you just sort of give
up you stop trying to make sense of
everything
you stop hoping that things will ever
quite feel right again
and you start feeling less in general
i've become a lot tougher now calloused
over with a sort of apathetic crust
admittedly i don't know if you would
even really like this version of me
i often don't recognize myself but
without you
i could never be that person i was again
more than a piece of me died with you
it was a whole version i often find it
hard to understand
the feeling of missing you when i don't
really know where you went
where did you go everything you were all
the character traits
the feelings and beliefs the thoughts
the ideas
the potential the collection of cells
and atoms that built into the expression
of a warm
youthful enthusiastic self they've
changed into something else now
the particles now spreading out and
dispersing across time and space
elsewhere
never to be you again the clocks don't
turn back
i've tried time only goes one way
through age through apathy through death
i knew that before but i hadn't really
felt it now i know it
and feel it that must be what it means
to truly know the truth of something
it's more than knowledge it's more than
sense it's the intersection of both
and as they say the truth hurts
i always hated that saying but i get it
now
we must be the only living things that
desire truth even though the truth
almost always reveals itself
to go against what we desire we are
masochists in denial
i know you would want me to be happy to
go on about life as if nothing changed
and everything was still the same but
everything changed
and nothing is the same and you nor i
can change that you couldn't have and
can't know now what it is like to live
in a world without you
you couldn't have accurately predicted
or imagined it and you can't be here now
to know or convince me otherwise only i
can know what it's like
and let me assure you it is a hard time
indeed
you would be how i am i guarantee it
that's how it works
i still have so much i want to
experience and see and talk about with
you
all the adventures that will never be
all the excitement and sensations i will
never feel
you are the child in me i can never
return to
you made simple little things exciting
and fun
i can do mostly all the same stuff still
but i don't
not really i mean i do sometimes but
it doesn't really feel like the same
stuff you made life scary
and unclear but it felt real now
life is quieter simpler and more stable
and it feels like very little the debt i
currently pay in grief and apathy
is perhaps the price of the potency of
the life i lived with you
you aren't truly dead yet sometimes i
feel you
i see you you poke out from the
mundanity when i see the sky's blueness
extra vividly when i feel momentarily
inspired to try something or go
somewhere different
when things feel light and new i will at
the very least
continue to carry your memories and
these momentary appearances
for as long as i can and as long as i
can
in the same way a version of me died
with you a version of you
will remain alive with me you're the one
who died
and yet i am the one who must try to
live again i am the remains of life that
you have left behind in your wake
and now your remains are what i must
hold on to
in order to feel alive as often as i can
even if just for a fleeting moment that
is what i will do
and that will have to be enough
you